Doreen grandpay is a clinical
psychologist and founder of the Center
for Autism and Related Disorders known
as card
founded in 1990 card focuses on applied
Behavior Analysis a therapy that claims
to increase helpful behaviors in
children with autism
an immigrant from Iran Grande piche
studied children with autism as a
student at UCLA before founding card
based on her studies as a graduate
student there
I came to the United States in 1978 and
that was the year
that there was a revolution in Iran and
shortly after the revolution they took
the American hostages in the U.S embassy
so it was very difficult for us as
Iranians living in the U.S
I started attending UCLA so I was really
young as a student in University and it
was a very big university so I was very
lost it was also that because there was
a revolution happening in Iran I had
completely lost contact with my parents
because they were in hiding from the
Khomeini regime
so I had no contact and I had to find a
job in order to be able to pay for
University I had taken a course in
social psychology and I loved just kind
of seeing how people are different in
groups as opposed to individuals and it
was just fascinating so very quickly I
got involved with a course in Psychology
and the professor was a gentleman by the
name of Ivar lovas
I left UCLA in 1990 with my doctorate
and
I had mostly focused on autism because I
was at UCLA for a long time I had been
overseeing the clinic there so I knew
how to train people then I went back to
autism and I founded card the Center for
Autism and Related Disorders and I
started seeing people who had children
with autism and started teaching them
all the things I had learned at UCLA
very quickly a family that I had met in
New York who had two children on the
spectrum of autism both of her children
had done the type of therapy that we did
at UCLA and both of her children
recovered so she wrote a book called let
me hear your voice and it became a
bestseller and in the book she talked
about me and how I had given guidance to
her team and helped them get where they
were
so because of that a lot of families in
New York were contacting me and asking
for help
so I decided I have to send someone out
to New York and open a clinic in New
York so New York was actually my second
Clinic my first one being in Los Angeles
and it was a little difficult because I
was the only supervisor and I had
therapists in both places but eventually
I trained someone to be a supervisor in
New York as well
around 1994 Grand Boucher met a family
in San Jose that was looking for help
for their autistic daughter
while helping the child the father asked
grandpay to open a card site in San Jose
but grumpiche said she would only open
one if he could find a group of families
that needed help
through an early online chat room the
man found plenty of families with
autistic children that were seeking help
through this therapy so my third site
was San Jose and he then went on this
larger group on online and wrote Oh
Doreen will open a clinic in your
location if you have 25 or so children
and so that was all the marketing that I
did for the next 10 years or so because
then I had families reaching out from
North Carolina and then England and
Australia and just all over the world
when I started card there was the UCLA
Clinic which was very small and really
much more experimental there were not a
lot of people providing this service it
was all private funding so it was also
difficult to access but over the years
mainly starting from our work at UCLA
but then also with replication studies
we proved that this type of intervention
works and that's why we were able to get
health coverage as well
in the very beginning the first few
years there was pretty much no Public
Funding so parents were paying for our
services and this is expensive because
the type of therapy we do is very
intensive so one child might be
receiving 40 hours of one-to-one therapy
per week so that's very expensive for
the parents to pay for and then after a
little while there's a law called the
free and appropriate Education Act and
that law says that if a school district
cannot provide the appropriate education
for your child they are obligated to
hire someone who can
so a lot of parents started using that
and hiring me and states by state though
there was a very good lawyer in New York
actually who made that happen for a lot
of families and so I was providing a lot
of service here funded by the districts
Grand piche isn't without her critics
however applied Behavior Analysis has
faced criticism that it's too tough on
children as the therapy historically
used punishment to help shape Behavior
while many Physicians no longer use
punitive measures critics say the
therapy focuses too much on trying to
make people with Autism appear quote
unquote normal
grandpay has also faced criticism for
her views on the origins of autism
while many experts believe autism is
caused by a combination of genetic and
environmental factors Grandpa's support
for the theory that the body's inability
to get rid of quote-unquote toxins and
role of vaccines as one such toxin in
contributing to autism is controversial
so I want to explain what I think is the
origin of autism and then I think it'll
become apparent why some people
criticize that
um I believe that autism and I've been
around for a really long time seen
thousands of children seen the whole
history of autism kind of evolve you
know when I started in this field people
believed autism was because of a cold
parenting there's the refrigerator
mother you know then there was a period
of time that everybody was having
children with autism swim with dolphins
to become cured I mean I've seen all
kinds of things over the course of the
last 45 years of being in this field
autism is a genetic predisposition that
is triggered by something environmental
and the question is what are those two
components what is the genetic part and
what is the Environmental part I believe
the genetic part has a lot to do with
slow redox so not being able to detoxify
fast enough and then I believe that the
environmental part has to do with toxins
so that's kind of my belief and I know
that there's a lot of controversy around
vaccines and I don't think vaccines are
alone responsible for this by any means
sometimes people think that I'm
anti-vaccines I'm not not at all in any
way in fact I think one of the best
things we ever did in humanity is is the
development of vaccines but I think that
what happens with children with autism
is that we overload them and at some
point depending on how much and what age
the child was exposed to toxicity they
can't detox anymore in time card grew to
more than 200 sites and became harder to
manage
at the same time private Equity firms
were getting involved in the applied
Behavior Analysis space
leading grumpiche to consider offers for
card to help continue its growth
in 2018 Blackstone bought card in a deal
valuing it at 600 million dollars
Grandpa walked away with approximately
300 million dollars pre-tax and stepped
down as CEO in 2019. personally if I was
to make the decision again today I
wouldn't sell it I think these types of
services health care when it comes to
young children with disabilities you
have to have a clinician at the hill
it's very important to continue to think
about
the patients and continuously focus on
the clinical side of the practice and
it's difficult when there isn't a
clinician at the helm because I'm a
clinician there was always a big part of
me that wanted to invest in making the
program better I put in a lot of money
into my research and development I'm
glad I did that because
the brand of the company became so well
known and so high quality and that was a
big part of why we succeeded in the end
my advice for young people going into
the field of autism treatment who will
be social workers or psychologists or
behavior analysts or behavior
technicians
I really have one piece of advice
um you may have gone to school for a
long time like I did but nobody knows
your patients better than their parents
and their family or them themselves so
listen and really understand your
patients in all possible ways understand
their life understand their physical
health their mental health understand
all of it so that when you're treating
the individual you're treating them as a
whole person
in June 2023 several weeks after this
interview was filmed card filed for
bankruptcy card has entered an agreement
to sell itself to pantogram a company
partly owned by grandpay for 25 million
dollars if it does not receive a higher
bid in the sale process
[Music]
thank you